[Music]
all right so we are moving on to the
next question and this one comes from I
believe sheldan alador and I saw was
putting some good comments in the chat
so Shel sheldan is asking for a friend
in the Bible men were marrying younger
women are these councils against or
excuse me are there councils against
this if the woman is 9 to 10 years old
if the I guess that should be if the man
is 9 to 10 years older than the woman
Spirit of Prophecy talks about a
disparity of age
right there uh there are biblical and
biological
reasons why the man ideally should be
older we know a man in the 70s and 80s
can father a child we know that a woman
after I don't know the exact ages maybe
late 40s early 50s can't do that and so
biologically it makes sense to have the
woman younger you understand because her
fertility expires much sooner than a man
okay secondly this may sound
insignificant but Adam was made first
whether he was older by a few seconds or
a few minutes he was made first and so
that makes the Man Slightly older than
the woman ly gives us great counsel and
she suggests that the the man should be
older the Gap should not be great I'm
not sure if she gives a precise age as
to the Gap in the difference in ages
that depends on the general ages of the
couple for instance um an 18-year-old
boy do doesn't need a 26y old girlfriend
they're emotionally different are you
following they're emotionally different
now a 56y old man can have a 64e wife I
mean that's fine because you know in
many ways they're virtually the same and
so it depends on what is your age range
if you are 18 and the young lady why do
you have a boyfriend who's 37 it makes
absolutely no sense at all or a boy
who's 18 has a girlfriend who's 38 now
there's no law that says Thou shalt not
do it but you know Common Sense is part
of the religion of God and so so yes
ideally the man should be or
biologically he is he has a longer time
span in which to rep father children
this is not the case with the lady and I
speak with respect also biblically God
made Adam first and so there's a reason
for that and so he was a little older
not by much we don't know how much time
elapsed between Adam's creation and
evees but he was made for seek in first
and so generally speaking yes let the
man be older uh I read I'm no expert
that women mature emotionally more
quicker than men and so if if you're 21
22 as a man and your girlfriend is 30
well maybe you need a girlfriend who's
18 but the general rule is the man is
older and don't have a great Gap but the
older you get the less the Gap matters I
mean an 80y old man with 90y old woman
what's the
difference but a 17-year-old boy with a
30-y old woman we have a problem
M and I there's a man asking me that
question uh please get a lady who's
younger than you in so far as it is
possible amen amen and you know I I've
honestly been seeing a lot of younger
women like in the church marrying men
that are way older than them and I've
just wondered about that as well because
I I've read some counsel on that about
Ellen White saying that you know within
10 years really should be the age range
but I do have to you know look back on
that and really research it White's son
WC white he married a woman about 20
years or 21 years older than himself but
El white loved her I mean she was part
of the wedding she approved
wholeheartedly and so sometimes El
White's Council has to be read very
carefully within the context and the
time and the circumstances where it was
given because I think he remarried WC
White and the woman was about 20 years
older than he was and El white was
enthusiastic she loved him she approved
she gave a blessing everything was hky
Dory and so we have to read some of her
counsel carefully what were the C
cumstances what was the context what was
going on when she wrot R if you don't do
that we may misjudge El white severely
and she doesn't need
that well thank youi I did not know that
so I gotta do some reearch
research all right